So, to summarize.
In the English legal system, there are three different types of court:...
...civil courts, criminal courts and tribunals which act as courts.
We have looked at the cases that are likely to be heard in each type of court.
Trespass is a tort and the plaintiff will sue in the civil courts.
Assault can be both a crime and a tort; and the case could be brought in either the civil court...
...or the criminal court, depending on the circumstances.
In a civil case of assault, the plaintiff will sue for damages...
...while in a criminal case, the police might charge a person with grievous bodily harm.
Theft is a crime and cases of theft are heard in the criminal courts.
Tribunals which act as courts and have a judicial rather than administrative function...
...include the Employment Appeal Tribunal.
This tribunal would hear cases of wrongful dismissal by an employer, for example.
Okay, that's it for today.
Next time, we'll look in detail at trespass to the person.
And don't forget to do a bit of research on that before you come.
Thanks.
See you soon.